agathe remercie d'être là ne se soit pas
déjà retraite axial mais non mais t'as
jamais voulu arrêter balances ton post
non je crois que tu vois là c'est assez
c'est aussi tout on kiffe d'être avec
nous moi ça me fait salle comble
vendredi soir ont maintenant deux
auditions attendues à koh lanta ça je
pourrais regarder koh lanta demain soir
je suis pas pour mais bon tu fais ça tu
as regardé je regarde également alors
agathe bon je sais te faire rigoler
parce que voilà c'est ce qu'on essaie de
faire à chaque fois et depuis que
conques on le sait on essaie toujours
voilà d'être avec toi et de te faire
rigoler pourquoi tu as pris cette
décision a à ce moment là pour les
téléspectateurs et tu pourras tu tenais
un moment il faut que je le dise à ce
moment là c'est le moment parce que si
tu l'as eu il ya combien de temps tu la
cia j'ai fait mes premiers examens en
septembre
on a eu un début de diagnostic en
octobre novembre et on a commencé le
protocole de soins mi-décembre d'accord
et tu es donc ces quatre cas pour après
à peu près de trois mois après le le le
les premiers soins pourquoi tu étais tu
t'es dit quoi bas et en plus je me
rappelle que c'est l'une des premières
choses que je t'ai dit parce que donc je
lui avais demandé ce que parce qu'il
était au courant ses îles j'ai dit je
veux je veux absolument continuer
l'émission surtout ne m'enlève pas de
l'émission tant que je suis en capacité
de le faire je veux le faire il m'a dit
mais bien sûr il n'en est pas question
et je vais évidemment des surtout n'en
parle à personne et je voulais
absolument que personne ne soit au
courant parce que je me disais que ça
allait peut-être être plus simple à
gérer ce que je m'attendais aussi
forcément à peut-être des articles ou
des réactions je n'avais pas envie de
2,2 d'appréhender ou de recevoir je sais
pas donc j'en parlais très peu voire
jamais et au fur et à mesure du
traitement qui est un traitement assez
lourd mais que je vis et que je vis très
bien
ça devenait complètement schizophrénique
j'étais dans une négation totale de la
maladie je veux je me persuader que ce
n'était absolument pas malade et je
vivais une espèce de double vie à
l'hôpital en dehors de l'hôpital ça
devenait un peu compliqué à gérer pour
moi et comme là comme l'a expliqué karim
sur instagram notamment qu'est le réseau
que sur lesquels je suis suivi par des
centaines de milliers de personnes je
partage des petites breeam de mon
quotidien
quotidiennement donc avec les gens qui
me suivent
et pareil je trouvais ça un peu
malhonnête j'étais rentré dans quelque
chose qui me qui me convenait pas
plus en phase avec moi-même je me
sentais mal à l'aise avec moi même et
donc j'ai écrit ce petit texte que j'ai
envoyée à ma mère à qui était bien sûr
au courant et qui est avec moi depuis le
début mai pour lui dire que j'allais
l'annoncer publiquement que j'ai envoyée
à ma meilleure amie à cyril évidemment
et je leur ai dit voilà je vais
l'annoncer comme ça c'est fait on n'en
parle plus et si ça peut aider des
personnes qui sont dans le même cas que
moi et qui ressentent cette solitude cet
isolement
cette culpabilité même parfois on a un
peu honte on sait pas trop comment gérer
cette maladie
quand je parce que moi je suis
complètement obsédée par mes cheveux
j'avais j'avais absolument j'avais
tellement peur que que ça me fasse faire
des shows parce que c'est un traitement
qui fait tomber les cheveux donc moi je
vois que j'ai perdu énormément de
cheveux pour les gens qui ne connaissent
pas ou à la télé ça se voit pas vraiment
mais moi je sais que je me réveille dans
un amoncellement de cheveux tous les
jours que je passe l'aspirateur toutes
les dix minutes
ces turbines dans les packs doc gynéco
non non malheureusement pour moi j'adore
seul mais non mais c'est c'est pour dire
que je sentais que ça allait avoir des
répercussions peut-être physique et que
c'était beaucoup plus sain de l'assumer
c'était devenu malsain de le dissimuler
coûte que coûte
et donc voilà je les fais sans y
réfléchir trop je sais ce que ça vous a
est ce que est ce que ça vous a soulagé
ce qu'aujourd'hui vous sentez mieux vous
dites voilà j'ai ça c'est un poids qui
est parti ou housse et voilà ça n'a pas
changé grand chose si je me sens mieux
dans ma vie tous les jours par exemple
je je je mettais que des cols très haut
même quand il a fait chaud un moment
parce que j'avais absolument peur qu'on
voit une [ __ ] un petit bout de ce fameux
cathéter est là maintenant je peux
sortir avec des t-shirts tout à fait
simple si on l'aperçoit c'est pas très
grave
je peux sortir avec les cheveux dans un
état c'est pas très grave je me mets
plus cette pression que je m'étais mise
moi même d'ailleurs sur les épaules je
vis beaucoup plus sereinement avec la
maladie sans lui laisser trop de place
dans ma vie bien sûr mais je les
complètement acceptés dont je suis dans
une démarche beaucoup plus beaucoup plus
honnête et surtout ce qui m'a fait un
bien fou
et ce à quoi je ne m'attendais pas
vraiment c'est donc ce flot de réactions
de messages etc de gens qui m'expliquait
être dans des cas similaires de cancer
de lymphome de maladies auto immunes ou
que serge est comme gelée j'ai essayé de
le faire passer dans mon message
instagram je le vis
comme une fatalité j'étais pas dans un
discours larmoyant j'essayais de faire
pleurer personne vraiment parce que
vraiment je vais bien je le vis le mieux
possible et et ça ne m'atteint pas ça
n'atteint pas mon esprit mon énergie je
suis toujours
c'était le sujet voilà en fait vous êtes
vous êtes heureux de cette décision
alors c'est un stade où je vois là on
vous avait dit un instant il ya plein de
gens qui ont dit qu'is salle ça leur a
fait du bien d'entendre ça parce que ça
leur a permis à eux aussi de sentir
mieux et de se dire voilà elle partage
le même quotidien que moi on a dans le
public muriel qui a 41 ans qu'elle
voulait absolument être là ce soir
elle a été victime d'un cancer du sein
il ya cinq ans à 36 ans et elle voulait
vous remercier levé vous un les îles
mariannes
merci d'être le cas vous êtes magnifique
merci merci muriel alors muriel vous
lire merci agathe juste parce que
apparemment eux
elle vous a fait du bien bah écoute et
oui ça fait du mal et la barre les biens
dans le micro merci à surseoir à tout ça
merci mais rien bonsoir agathe la force
à je voulais dire que oui ça fait du
bien en fait de parler de la maladie
moi ce comme toi j'en ai parlé très
rapidement je suis passé aussi par la
phase essayé de cacher bon moi j'avais
des dreadlocks depuis dix ans donc je
pouvais pas me retrouver d'un seul coup
sans cheveux donc c'est vrai que j'ai eu
cette petite phase après j'en ai parlé
tout de suite librement et comme vous
dites en fait c'est par rapport à la
personnalité de chacun parce qu'après il
faut aussi savoir que quand on le dit
faut supporter aussi le flou des gens
qui vont venir faut supporter aussi des
gens qui font pas la différence qui vont
venir vous raconter qu'il ya 36 cancer
dans leur famille alors que vous vous
êtes déjà au fond du trou
donc non donc c'est vrai que faut avoir
la personnalité après mois pour
connaître un peu à l'émission cyril
agathe et tout d'ailleurs cyril merci
parce que tu m'as fait passer le cap
mon frère franchement de la chimio de
tous les traitements
j'avais besoin de divertissement tu es
tombé à pic et france
merci merci merci mme lauria les écoutes
franchement bas aujourd'hui je te dis tu
es magnifique merci garde peut sourire
merci parce qu'il nous fait du bien
aussi
merci était vraiment est une bombe voilà
merci merci et puis alors je veux dire
j'ai un petit livre pour agathe d'accord
alors les livres ça me connaît entendu
tu sais que à la merci alors c'est quoi
c'est quoi ce livre alors c'est un
monsieur que j'ai fait c'est ok d'accord
ni alors france
ça c'est avec des photos pour les
cheveux en fait voilà cancer attitude
cancer air attitude a les cheveux en
engrais il demandé merci et c'est une
bonne idée ça c'était une bonne idée
parce que en fait les cheveux bas le
disais c'est le moi j'avais plus peur de
perdre mais dreadlocks du coup que
d'aller à la chimio ouais c'est donc les
cheveux c'est vraiment c'est un passage
qui est très très difficile et on n'en
parle pas beaucoup en se disant c'est un
détail est en fait moi j'ai fait toute
une série de photos le jour où je me
suis rasé et j'ai tout mis avec des
citations pour aider les personnes
justement qui vont passer par là merci
mais juste un dernier
je voudrais juste passer un petit coup
de gueule par rapport aux gens qui t'ont
coûte la halle quand on passe des coups
de gueule ses lentilles c'est pas moi
non mais attends octogone aussi en asie
bon alors du coup en fait c'est un coup
de gueule sur quoi se base sur le mépris
justement par rapport et le manque de
considération par rapport aux personnes
en situation de handicap par rapport aux
personnes qui sont diminués alors moi
c'est vrai que j'ai un handicap
invisible parce qu'après le cancer
j'enchaîné avec une rupture d'anévrisme
cérébral comme ça a été hyper lourd
hyper difficile et en fait vous vous
retrouver financièrement c'est l'enfer
le service public c'est vrai moi je
soutiens le milieu hospitalier parce
qu'il ya des choses à revoir mais du
coup c'est nous qui subissons les
mauvaises énergies les gens en fait
parfois n'ont pas le temps et
honnêtement comme je disais avant il ya
peut-être une ou deux personnes qui
étaient désagréables dans un service
maintenant vous avez uni deux personnes
qui est sympa donc ça c'est quelque
chose qui est vraiment difficile les
aides
moi j'ai voulu me reprendre passer à
autre chose passer mon permis du coup je
me suis retrouvé en galère j'ai fait une
demande des d'exceptionnel on me l'a
refusé
j'ai demandé à changer de logement parce
qu'ils n'étaient plus adaptés par
rapport à ma rupture d'anévrisme
homme-là refusé en fait c'est à dire que
si les gens qui sont déjà valides sont
fatigués en ce moment sap annuels sont
de faire
ouais moi je suis fatigué en fait
d'aller
essayer de me faire entendre d'essayer
de passer un message d'essayer
d'améliorer mon quotidien
alors que je suis déjà en mode pékin
express avec le handicap n'a sûrement
tout cas merci mais j'espère est-ce que
parce que la dernière chose à nous dire
ce que vous avez peut-être une question
à poser à gâteau de la table parce que
on va passionner monsieur mais juste à
garder ce que tu as quelque chose à dire
encore oui jusque parmi les messages que
je reçois en ce moment il y en a pas mal
du corps médical justement et
hospitaliers des médecins chirurgiens et
de soignants infirmières anesthésistes
et serra qui me disent pour répondre à
la question de base que justement quand
on a cette petite voix à ma petite
échelle
on peut avoir un écho ou une résonance
et qu'on s'en sert dans cette démarche
de sensibilisation de la maladie du
cancer du lymphome surtout que le mien
touche en particulier les jeunes de 15 à
30 ans en particulier cette cible là
c'est c'est primordial pour eux d'être
dans cette démarche d'ouverture d'ouvrir
la discussion de faire connaître ces
maladies de les banaliser non pas pour
les rendre moins grave mais moins tabou
et que les draps et dès que ça plairait
beaucoup de gens un autre effet positif
c'est que tout d'un coup les réseaux
sociaux sont noyés sous un flot
bienveillance qui est pas de registre
habituel des réseaux sociaux non non non
c'est une note défend les réseaux
sociaux mais d'habitude le rgi c'est
plutôt l'insultent la haine la
diffamation et là tout d'un coup ça
c'est moi qui me fait passer pour des
mecs là que tout d'un coup ça change un
peu la vision de l'humanité qu'on aille
à queue de la bienveillance envers
agathe qui a déclenché quelque chose moi
je trouve que c'est très positif tant de
coeur et autant de fleurs pendant deux
trois jours et des cursus est issu merci
en tout cas gâteux va revoir
je veux simplement dire que le choix
d'agathe il faut aussi de percevoir dans
ce qu'elle est en réalité agathe
elle a peut-être été connue elle est
peut-être connu suivi parce que c'est
une belle fille elle est effectivement
elle est éblouissante mais c'est pas que
c'est pas qu'une façade c'est pas qu'une
beauté
c'est aussi à l'intérieur c'est aussi
des valeurs quand on la connaît je
trouve que ta démarche elle participe
aussi de cela parce que quelque part tu
le fais certainement pour toi mais pas
que pour toi jeu comme je te connais je
sais que tu es très porté sur sur autrui
et je crois que cette cette révélation
qui l'a fait aussi parce que tu veux
être utile dans le cadre des combats qui
sont à mener contre la maladie
tu va le gagner pour ce qui te concerne
mais tu as un oratoire et de gagner
[Applaudissements]
encore voilà en tout cas je moi je suis
sûr que ça voilà j'espère que ça sera
plus qu'un mauvais souvenir dans
quelques mois je sais que là vous êtes
toi vous êtes à mi chemin au niveau du
traitement exactement bombe en tout cas
on est là on est là pour voir ça surtout
de retrouver tous vos camarades sont
donc vous êtes très émue à sa me fait un
bien fou un bien fou je les aime tous
énormément peut pas imaginer btp sans
toi impossible ce que je suis contente
depuis l'autre côté de top ce qui
finalement est en face de toi je vois
que tu tiennes cours plus bel effort il
est fort il est trés touareg du drame
merci en tout cas à vous pour tous vos
messages pour agathe et agathe mais
surtout c'est qu'on est là pour te
soutenir on te lâchera pas et je sais
que tu vas gagner ce combat et on le
gagnera à tes côtés parce qu'on ne
lâchera pas voilà et tu vois que tu as à
la tène familles qui étaient les
spectateurs avec tous les personnes ici
et j'espère et tu as bien sûr ta famille
qui est de soutirer énormément